-Elle a fait ses gammes à droite
avec Alain Madelin puis Alain Juppé.
Désormais membre
de Renaissance,
elle occupe un poste stratégique
à l'Assemblée.
Générique
...
-Bonjour.
-En 2017,
quand vous êtes arrivée
à l'Assemblée,
vous aviez à peine 40 ans
et déjà plus de 20 ans
d'expérience
quand la plupart
de vos collègues
de La République En Marche
débutaient
en politique. On a retrouvé
des images de vous
qui datent de 1996.
A l'époque,
vous étiez engagée
au sein du syndicat étudiant UNI
et vous vous apprêtiez
à rencontrer Jacques Chirac
à Amiens.
*-A 19 ans,
en première année de droit,
elle s'est engagée à fond
pour le candidat Chirac.
Elle aussi sera du déjeuner.
*-On va faire un bilan
sur l'orientation,
sur le procédé sélectif
qui n'est pas terrible
à l'université,
on va parler
d'insertion professionnelle,
du statut de l'étudiant
et du statut social.
-Quand on vous entend
faire la liste de tous les sujets
que vous voulez aborder
avec Jacques Chirac...
-Je n'ai pas rempli la mission.
-Il y avait déjà ce côté
très carré,
très sérieux chez vous,
vous n'étiez pas là
pour aller faire
des blagues
avec Jacques Chirac.
-Oui, mais alors,
c'est amusant
parce que je crois qu'au déjeuner,
j'ai réussi à lui dire qui j'étais.
-C'est pas allé plus loin ?
-J'ai fait une remarque,
mais c'était impressionnant
de le voir.
C'est vrai qu'on se mettait
pas mal de pression.
C'était mon 1er engagement,
on m'envoyait déjeuner
avec le président.
-On le voit,
à la sortie du déjeuner,
sur le perron de la préfecture.
C'est la campagne présidentielle
de Jacques Chirac
qui a déclenché
votre premier engagement.
Vous avez soutenu
sa campagne, sauf que
vous ne vous définissez pas
comme chiraquienne.
-Je crois qu'au fond...
Je vais le dire
de façon très franche,
je pense que j'ai été rapidement
un peu déçue de...
De l'action
qu'il avait menée et puis,
maintenant que j'ai vieilli,
je me rends compte que les choses
sont moins simple
et que "déçue", c'est trop fort,
mais non, je ne me considérais pas
comme chiraquienne.
J'étais plus sensible
à la personnalité
d'Alain Madelin.
-Oui.
Ca, c'est à partir de 1999.
-Oui, mais en 1995,
il est membre du gouvernement
de Jacques Chirac
et d'Alain Juppé,
il est ministre
de l'Economie et des Finances,
et il démissionne rapidement
après avoir été nommé
et j'avais, à l'époque,
estimé qu'au fond, c'était la preuve
d'une forme de cohérence
avec ses convictions et ça m'avait
impressionnée positivement.
-Alain Madelin,
c'est la droite libérale,
vous avez milité
dans son parti
à partir de 1999,
vous avez dirigé le mouvement
des Jeunes avec Madelin
et quand il a intégré l'UMP,
vous l'avez suivi et là,
c'est Alain Juppé
que vous avez rencontré,
qui a été le premier
président de l'UMP.
Sur le papier,
vous n'étiez pas
faits pour vous entendre
et ça s'est bien passé.
Il vous a fait confiance.
Comment vous expliquez
que l'alchimie
se soit bien faite
entre vous ?
-Ben parce que, Alain Juppé,
c'est quelqu'un
qui... Qui est
très à l'écoute,
contrairement
à ce que l'image peut passer,
peut laisser penser de lui,
c'est quelqu'un
qui est très à l'écoute
et qui a une vraie considération
pour la jeunesse.
J'ai pu l'observer
quand j'étais jeune et après,
j'ai pu l'observer... avec lui
parce que j'ai cheminé longtemps
avec Alain Juppé,
puisque j'ai commencé...
Je l'ai rencontré en 2002,
vous l'avez dit,
et j'ai fait sa campagne...
-En 2016.
-Voilà, j'ai fait sa campagne
pour les primaires
de la droite
et du centre en 2016
et j'ai eu l'occasion d'observer
qu'avec les jeunes de 2016,
dont je ne faisais
plus partie,
il avait la même écoute,
la même bienveillance
et le même intérêt,
et donc, c'était,
pour quelqu'un de 25, 26, 27 ans,
je ne sais plus
quel âge j'avais,
mais avoir
un ancien Premier ministre,
président de parti
et présidentiable
qui s'intéresse à vous,
à votre point de vue
et à celui
de votre génération,
c'était pas dur
de bien s'entendre avec lui.
-Vous avez créé
les Jeunes populaires,
vous en avez été
la 1re présidente,
vous avez côtoyé
beaucoup de personnalités
que vous croisez aujourd'hui
à l'Assemblée
dans les rangs RN, LR
ou de la majorité :
Franck Allisio, Sébastien Chenu,
Aurélien Pradié,
Virginie Duby-Muller,
Aurore Bergé, Gérald Darmanin,
Benjamin Haddad
et encore, je crois
qu'il y en a d'autres.
C'était une bonne école
de la politique,
les Jeunes Pop ?
-Les mouvements de jeunesse
en général,
c'est une école de la politique,
certains disent du vice...
-C'était la phrase
de Mitterrand
sur les Jeunes Socialistes.
-On n'était pas
des Jeunes Socialistes,
donc j'ai pas le sentiment
d'avoir vécu dans l'école du vice.
C'était vraiment
très formateur.
J'en retire d'abord
une bande de copains,
qui ne sont pas forcément
ceux que vous avez cités.
-Vous aviez repéré
Aurélien Pradié.
-Ouais.
Il était tout jeune.
Il avait 16 ans.
Il était impressionnant, Aurélien,
parce qu'à 16 ans,
il montrait qu'il avait
du potentiel, oui.
Il semblerait
que ça n'ait pas été démenti.
-Vous avez aussi
traversé des moments
plus difficiles, notamment
quand Nicolas Sarkozy
a repris en main l'UMP.
Il vous a demandé
de démissionner.
C'est aussi ça,
la politique,
cet aspect
qui peut être violent ?
-Il ne m'a pas
exactement demandé
de démissionner.
-Il vous a poussée
à la démission,
on va dire.
-Je savais qu'en me présentant
à la présidence des Jeunes de l'UMP,
que j'ai remportée,
je savais qu'il était pas
en soutien
de ma candidature.
-Ils vous voyait
comme trop pro-Juppé,
trop pro-Chirac alors que...
-Et pas assez pro-lui.
-Pas assez pro-Sarkozy.
-Ce n'était pas forcément faux,
mais pas forcément vrai non plus.
Bon, bref, quand on préside un parti
et qu'on veut être président,
on a envie d'avoir un mouvement
de jeunes qui obéit avec le doigt
sur la couture du pantalon.
L'enjeu est tellement grand
que je le comprends.
Je pense qu'on aurait pu
être gérés différemment,
mais c'est pas grave,
c'est passé, tout ça.
Mais oui, on m'a présentée
comme l'anti-Sarkozy,
je ne l'étais, au fond,
pas à ce point.
-Ca ne vous a pas empêchée
de continuer dans des cabinets
ministériels, au Conseil général
des Yvelines et en 2016,
vous avez donc
participé
à la campagne d'Alain Juppé.
En 2017,
l'affaire Fillon éclate
et là,
entre les deux tours,
vous vous tournez
vers Emmanuel Macron.
Il faut se rappeler
qu'à l'époque,
à ce moment précis,
il y avait pas mal
de ralliements à gauche,
mais assez peu à droite.
Ca a été une décision
difficile à prendre pour vous ?
-Oui et non. Non parce que,
par rapport à beaucoup d'amis
qui avaient des responsabilités
politiques, des mandats,
moi, je n'ai engagé
que moi-même.
Je n'avais pas grand-chose
à justifier. Ce n'était
qu'un choix personnel,
et oui, c'était difficile
parce qu'on n'était
pas nombreux à le faire
et que,
quand vous retournez
vers vos amis
qui militent depuis 20 ans
au même endroit que vous
et que vous êtes seule,
vous vous dites :
"J'aurais préféré..."
La politique, c'est avant tout
une aventure collective,
en tout cas,
c'est comme ça que je le vis,
et c'est vrai
que c'est un choix
que j'ai fait seule.
-Peur de passer pour une traître ?
-Oui, bien sûr.
-C'est ça,
le risque.
-C'est très compliqué de...
De... De... De faire en sorte,
de faire comprendre aux gens...
On va pas à la gamelle, en fait.
On fait ça par conviction.
On fait ça parce qu'on pense
que c'est le bon choix.
Je pense que les gens
qui me connaissent et qui ont pu
juger de mon engagement depuis
savent ce qu'il en est,
mais sur le moment,
il y a ce premier réflexe,
cette première...
Ce premier jugement
qui est porté sur le fait de...
La trahison,
donc...
-Il y a une image
en 2022 qui m'a marqué
à la fin de la cérémonie
d'investiture
d'Emmanuel Macron
à l'Elysée,
on le voit aller saluer
des personnalités
et puis, à un moment,
il s'arrête
pour vous saluer vous
et vous remercier
de ce que vous avez fait
pour lui
pendant le campagne présidentielle
et ça a surpris
pas mal
de journalistes politiques.
Comment vous l'expliquez ?
-Je suis peut-être sous les radars
des journalistes politiques.
-C'est un peu l'impression
que ça donne.
Ils n'ont peut-être pas pris
la mesure de votre rôle
dans cette campagne.
-Peut-être,
mais je n'ai pas cherché
à le valoriser.
-Vous le dites vous-même,
alors pourquoi ne pas chercher
à vous mettre plus en avant ?
Vous avez occupé
des fonctions importantes :
secrétaire de la campagne
d'Alain Juppé en 2016,
directrice financière
de celle de François Fillon
en 2017, trésorière
de La République En Marche,
puis déléguée générale
adjointe.
C'est des postes où on reste
dans l'ombre, en général.
-Oui, mais enfin, moi, je...
Je ne recherche pas la lumière.
Probablement que
je la craignais aussi,
et donc, au fond,
c'est quand même
plus simple d'évoluer dans l'ombre,
en tout cas, c'est probablement
moins de pression,
donc voilà.
Après, j'essaie
de faire sérieusement
mon travail, de faire en sorte
que les gens qui me font confiance
en soient contents,
Maintenant, j'ai une dimension...
Je suis élue, maintenant,
et donc, je sais qu'il y a
une part d'exposition
que je dois aussi prendre
parce que c'est
ce qu'on attend aussi
de ma fonction.
-Vous avez été élue
questrice de l'Assemblée
en 2022
aux côtés d'Eric Woerth
et d'Eric Ciotti. C'est une fonction
stratégique de l'Assemblée,
on va en parler,
mais là encore,
c'est une fonction
pas très connue du grand public.
-C'est un rôle...
fondamental.
-Sur le rôle,
les questeurs sont à la fois
trésoriers et préfets. On parle
souvent de ce côté trésorier,
vous gérez un budget conséquent.
Combien c'est ?
-600 millions d'euros.
-600 millions par an
pour l'Assemblée.
On retient moins souvent
la dimension préfet.
Qu'est-ce qu'on entend par là ?
-Pour faire simple,
les questeurs s'occupent
de la définition
et de l'exécution du budget,
accompagnent
le personnel de l'Assemblée,
1200 agents de la fonction
publique parlementaire
et des contractuels,
et ils s'occupent d'accompagner
les députés dans les moyens
qui sont les leurs
pour mener à bien leur mandat,
donc c'est
trois gros morceaux,
si je puis dire, et au fond,
vous touchez un peu
à tous les domaines, et donc,
c'est peut-être en ça
qu'il y a une fonction
de préfet.
-Un peu plus préfet.
Vous dites
que c'est un poste aussi,
voire plus stratégique
que secrétaire d'Etat.
Si on vous propose d'être
secrétaire d'Etat, vous direz non ?
-Je vais pas me faire
beaucoup de copains.
Non mais...
C'est comme tout...
Questeur, en tout cas,
c'est une responsabilité
très forte...
-Dans l'institution
de l'Assemblée.
-On touche à beaucoup de sujets,
j'ai cité les principaux
qui sont les ressources humaines,
le budget
et l'accompagnement des députés,
mais il y en a beaucoup d'autres :
le parc bâtimentaire,
les investissements
que l'on fait, il y a
la démarche environnementale,
il y a beaucoup de choses.
Ca ressemble
à maire d'une ville.
-Vous êtes
la maire de l'Assemblée.
On va passer à notre quiz,
à présent.
Je vais
commencer une phrase
et vous allez devoir
la compléter.
-Oui.
-On y va.
"Depuis que
je suis questrice,
"beaucoup de députés..."
Elle rit.
-Beaucoup de députés...
Elle hésite.
...font appel à moi pour...
Pour les aider
dans l'exercice de leur mandat.
-Pour régler des soucis.
-Ca va de sujets compliqués
à moins compliqués
de type chauffage
ou climatisation.
Il faut rester humble.
-"Les députés qui utilisent TikTok,
WhatsApp ou Instagram..."
-Essaie d'intéresser
les jeunes.
-J'avais en tête
ce communiqué
qui les invitait à faire attention
à leurs données
sur leur téléphone.
-Oui, tout à fait. On a voulu
sensibiliser nos collègues au fait
que l'utilisation
de ces réseaux
pouvait les exposer
et qu'il fallait être vigilant
à l'utilisation
de l'ensemble des réseaux sociaux
par le biais
des téléphones portables
qui sont les leurs. On ne peut pas
leur interdire de les utiliser,
mais ça nécessite
de la vigilance.
-"Quand je ne serai plus députée,
"je pourrai enfin..."
-Oh là là ! Faire plein de choses.
-La liste est longue ?
-Non, mais il y a
plein de choses que...
Que j'aimerais faire.
En premier lieu... En premier lieu,
je m'occuperai probablement plus
de ma famille
et il y a
plein d'autres choses
que j'aimerais faire,
mais je suis, honnêtement...
une femme très épanouie
dans la façon dont je gère mon temps
à la fois comme députée,
comme mère de famille
et comme individu,
donc tout va bien.
-Ce sera le mot de la fin.
Merci d'être
venue dans "La politique et moi."
-Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...